hi everyone thanks for joining us this
is what is it called the other show hey
everyone thanks for joining us on the
other show today we're talking about
episode six so we're gonna hear with
Helene Andrew as always and Molly
Shannon this is like my dream of being
an actress like on a show with a couch
[Laughter]
guess who's gonna be on watch what
happens live I love to like shoot watch
what happens live in character or now um
that was a little weird yeah it's
interesting because I have I've hardly
ever done that so it's it's very strange
because in real life I get nervous as
myself if I do a talk show that does
feel strange because you're not yourself
so you don't feel as nervous and you're
sitting next to Patrick Wilson playing
himself in character he was really nice
hi um I'm looking to get jacked fast do
you have a gym membership
no but it's kind of an emergency I'm
gonna be the bartender on watch what
happens live because it's just it's good
to be seen yeah totally I did that last
week you've been on watch what happens
live too but as the bartender right yes
I yes but you were right I was wearing
clothes I had like on a jacket like
buttoned up to my neck like I was like
ah I could not remember that
Guildenstern Rosencrantz he goes there
in live because I was so nervous like it
was just like sense memory of being
behind the bartender like thing again I
was like oh I'm nervous again it was
very funny because even in between takes
when people would be talking or giving
notes or something you were always just
standing back there by yourself in a
little boat I know there yeah I was
trying to conserve warmth also like you
had said like hey we don't have much
time in there so anytime we're in
between I was like no I wasn't rushing
the actor
excited I'm so nervous I could barf I
just hope I don't mess up tonight don't
be nervous you literally can't mess up
watch what happens like Molly your
character in particular is like super
starstruck I guess like mard they're
people to this day that you Molly
Shannon would still be starstruck around
yes there are oh yeah that you haven't
met or you've met them even still like
I'm back home and I still feel
starstruck like Angelina Jolie and I get
starstruck for housewives to like I said
like I - an Abba door and the LAX
Airport and I was like oh it's like the
desiccates opened up like I got very
excited I'm obviously a big motley fan
yeah and I was like if if during the
pilot when we were filming I was like if
it ever looks like the person acting
across from Molly is just a big fan of
hers and huge just tell me because I
felt like I was just kind of like
- we don't smell right dance until wings
yeah I I was told that there would be
dancing in this music video and they're
like there's gonna be a rehearsal and it
sort of sounded super casual and so I
was like um okay so I guess I have to
learn this dance and they weren't really
telling me the time they made it seem
like it was gonna be nothing and I
showed up for the rehearsal and I was
like this is real and then all of the
girls in that that did that music video
all the dancers are so good and and then
I was like god all of you guys are so
good I feel like I'm in a Beyonce video
and Kat the choreographer went oh these
girls do dance for Beyonce I was like oh
my one out one door of the rehearsal
room and like came back in the other
door and was like I'm ready to start
again they make you sad that you weren't
so dancing brookie no actually I like
what I'm doing plus if I had kept
dancing I'd be starting over now anyway
so yes in some ways I got a head start
that's beautiful thanks mom
no I mean the top that I'm wearing I
really am like Patti let's be honest
there's not really that no values values
values yeah what are Pat's values family
family family yeah yeah yeah and
spirituality yeah I think I was gonna
say just the way she is positive about
life and open I feel like that too I
tried I think I'm like that yeah I
relate to her we talked about that in
the writers room that we like about your
character or hopefully what we were
trying to do is not have her be like a
stage mom it's just sort of like sure I
love my son and everyone in America
saying they love him too so I guess I
love America I love this like yes like
just saying yes to things yes it was
done a year of yes or like made a
conscious effort to be like this year
I'm going for it I think I do like every
January and then by like February 2nd
I'm like I can't remember I don't know I
was gonna try to be more positive in
2018 and I made it to like May
[Laughter]
mom why did you say dad died of cancer
what do you mean that's what we decided
to tell chase yeah chase not the whole
viewing audience of watch what happens I
just figured Chase is gonna be watching
it later so did I miss out just in
general I love the idea of a woman this
isn't so much me cuz I'm married but I
love a woman having a very happy chapter
to where they you know her husband
passed away but she's really like alive
and so full without kind of a nice
chapter 2 at a nice age I just think
that's so true to life and I see a lot
of women really happy that way kind of
reinventing themselves yeah
maybe after a divorce or a death of a
spouse in a very positive way
yeah I just love that Oh Molly thank you
for being here pleasure
thank you for telling us about celebrity
[Music]
you